in a recent interview with Yahoo movies
thor ragnarok rider Erik Pearson
revealed that one planned scene was left
on the cutting-room floor it was a
spaghetti joke and it was pretty gross
we can't count the number of times
spaghetti has shown up as a gag in a
movie or show sometimes it's sweet other
times it's a little more disgusting but
the cutscene and thor ragnarok
might have been the most disgusting of
all behind the scenes the writers called
it the noodle worm scene which should
tell you how gross it was Pearson
explained it was an emotional check-in
moment with Bruce Banner and Thor before
the finale with banner eating alien food
and trying to be serious it looks like
spaghetti but then he realizes the thing
he's eating is alive on the end yep in
this case noodle worm was entirely
literal please Nick eat some biscotti I
didn't realize you enjoyed eating worms
Nick so why was the scene cut Pearson
went on to say I spent so much time on
it and it just never made it in we
thought it was this pivotal character
moment and it never had a place it
crushed the momentum the scene marks yet
another moment clip from Thor Ragnarok
which was originally going to include a
second major Thor villain and feature a
flashback scene of a chubby Thor and an
emo Loki cuts back to this thing and
he's just like this while I got the kid
am i lucky that this little like golf
that's emo golf maybe the noodle worm
will still make an appearance in a
future Thor movie although something
tells us you'd never look at a plate of
spaghetti the same way again
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]